PUBG Mobile
PUBG!
Drink lots of water if you're sweating be drinking, abd
We're gonna go out to the road, getting some vehicle shots as with any vehicle stuff
There's  of course a bit of a danger involved
I'm surprised the car didn't crash
sun is just now rising shoot ends when it sets we have a long day ahead of us
three honks means go
two honks means I am stopping
Slapping on the car
Today we are rocking the 8k Helium four to seven to Sigma lens variable there like sunglasses for your camera
Alright, the shot like this lot of moving parts lot of people
You're gonna film the whole take in one go. We need to walk through it with everybody make sure we all know how it's gonna work
In this shot we're gonna run the whole scene that means I'm going to have him get in the bus where are we throwing down the sandbags
And that's when we hit the body Danny
You're gonna be driving in the camera car you're gonna be in front of us don't hit the sandbags?
I come to a stop after hit them you throw the car in reverse and we're gonna back up over them again
Boom boom we're gonna stop and run the rest of the scene
Driving the imaginary car me and Sam are sitting here next to each other
Jake once we hit the body, which will be by the sandbags. You'll be waiting there just for now walk next to us
I really really appreciate it
Let's get the vehicles in position,
but here's the best part, you don't have to imagine any of this because this is actually the situation that were in
I'm just going over my lines
There's a lot of them, so I don't want to trip over any of them
And I still want them to feel natural so
my mom used to make me do this thing when I was a kid and remember
Math problems where I'd have to walk around the house and memorize math problems in my head
So I could just say them I always hated it
But I'm thanking her now because it makes it a lot easier to remember lines when you're acting
Thanks, mom.
All I'm trying to say is that friends are important
Back to one back to one now keep this pace up so you can get the ending scene done more character Niko
If someone's not giving the best performance just ask them ask them to give you more acting and
There you go, so it's about finding the right amount usually just need to ask for more until you get it
Yeah, the secret of Jack Nicholson's performance is he's always acting at 100%
very difficult for actors to reach that
So we've come to the conculsion that Dobby the trickster God lives in the desert because whenever we go to the desert
The ultimate tricks happen, it's currently 10:00 a.m.. And
We've been out here for at least two hours now, so I'm assuming we're a little behind because we're still getting the
Yeah, we just finished like the first set up. Yeah
I'm not getting any audio off the Sennheiser mic, and we're at the middle of the desert, so
It's nice and some I think it's just he's just a harmless mischievous trickster
God like haha your microphone doesn't work a little while it wouldn't transmit to our transmitter
It wasn't holding power we tried plugging into the camera then it'd work for a while
But then stopped working and kind of get buzzy come listen to what I just got because it's very
A lot of static and little by little throughout the day it got worse and worse
You know like when you're trying to fix something
You don't fix it instantly so then another person comes in and they're like here. Can I try and you're like well?
And then they kind of start trying anyways and then somebody else steps in goes no
no, let me try, and then you get like a chain of five or six people all trying to fix the same problem and just
It just gets worse
Setting we set all the settings and it started working. It's a hardware issue up the input volume. Just a little bit
Let's just do it you hit the arm it and I know play it's literally going to like -46
We're gonna do this we'll just film it and then we'll do wild lines in the van like hey Spencer you have any idea
What's going on here could and Spencer ascertained that well you asked the man himself?
We ended up finding out is the board inside of the microphone. It's what you put battery and what happens is
It'll work for a certain amount of time, and then it will cut off and die for a film shoot
You have to have it last of the entire time unbelievably Spencer. Also had a second shotgun microphone
Hot sauce
The car drive over those two sandbags, and then in post using visual magic place the bags with me shadow
flop
My name's Steve Dundee got a crocodile in me mouth
Can't say take what will come out and yet
Expect it when it is one shot one shot like we're literally hiking up that fucking Mountain so I want to bring a lot of
stuff
It's a specialty shot. It's a it's a pretty large amount of dirt. I say it's a mountain akin to
Kilimanjaro . It's a wide shot of the van driving, and then it's a
Zoom out and then see characters run in front of the floor down okay?
Nice nailed it. Oh Nico said we're not fired we got the shot. It was all worth it
we're trying to accomplish a following shot on the van and
Having the camera locked off with the dusty road is just way too shaky now
We're gonna have to literally just put the camera and Adrian on the roof
The boogie board
I'm good
wonderful I
heard on page
155 of Sam's top ten games you can play in your head by yourself. Oh my god is not the actual
Thanks to PUBG mobile for sponsoring this video if you're interested in downloading PUBG mobile click the link in the description. It's free
Am I about to get a chicken dinner unless I die
Please don't die
This is like literally the first time I've ever played this game
Between West Boise I see I see
That's across from you Norfolk. I kill them. Oh yeah kill sprint. This is intense. Ren over there who is using the gamertag
TechDad77 so if you go and friend him
you might have a chance to play with him online obviously it's really intense
Oh, that's that's that's great daddy's house unclear, but we're set here on soap. Oh, yeah, I just saw oh
It's the most robust mobile game, I think I've ever seen you're not playing PUBG mobile. You're just playing PUBG
Freeze oh and I died no frickin believe how robust this game is
Oh my god. We about to get the dinner. This is legitimately actually really fun. So I think you'll enjoy it look around some friends
One guys somewhere in you I am still bandaging up make sure in the circle dude aren't each get a red ball
Oh this, Missouri is not us if you're back behind you we're okay. That's definitely not me shooting I
Don't know I'm right behind you
I'm not I'm coming to the rock. Yeah you go
- lets go
Download PUBG mobile for free under the link in the description below
You simply go to your app store of your device and download it
PUBG Mobile has a new arcade mode with 28 players and one of the six following variations: shotguns, sniper rifles, all weapons, melee only,
pistols
and item heaven
The realistic graphics of the game are powered by Unreal Engine and you can communicate in real time with your team using in-game voice chat
Forgot to announce we are going to buy someone a chicken dinner. We're gonna send one person
chicken dinner from a restaurant in their area courtesy of corridor digital go online
Play PUBG mobile if you win in the game
Scree cap take that screen cap put it on instagram tag @corridordigital
We will randomly select one chicken dinner winner we will buy you a chicken dinner for you and your family
or you and your friends from somewhere in your hometown
Will pick somebody right after this video goes up. Hey bridges here
The face
Then both of them turn it and start shooting at me, and I take cover boom boom boom boom boom you'll be for the sunsets
Oh, we're losing sunlight quickly you can literally see the shadow moving we wrap. There's no real
There's no time so we got to move the bus to a clearing we can finish this fight scene
Driving it like a racing right there
And that's cut
Why are you putting the camera oh should I say something profound yeah?
Dogs oh crap Danny we need another lens now you need a lens. Yeah go get
You may remember Sam and I made a little bet
guaranteed
Two-day shipping so some some poor innocent
unknowing Amazon delivery
Contractor is gonna
Get this package, and they're gonna have to make the decision as to whether or not they want to drive a hundred miles one way
My goodness well. I sure hope they make it in time. I'll bet you two to one it arrives
I owe you 20 if it doesn't arrive on or before the 30th, then you owe me ten. Mmm. That's enough for that all right
Hey searching my email
Corridor, sorry we missed you we tried we tried
Yeah, we tried, but we weren't able to deliver your package today. You can reschedule you know
I don't need a rescheduling delivery. We did they didn't try no one tried
We know what maybe they shouldn't have guaranteed the to em day. Okay, so how does this work now?
They didn't that you didn't get the package so if it's guaranteed you should be able to get your money
Well the order was $25. I'll refund that I'll take down all those dollars on William Neal I
I don't think that's how it works